qui aime les livres aime les mots et les
jeunes mots alors à Chambéry on a
rajouté à la Fureur de Lire une
dimension poétique en baptisant la
nouvelle médiathèque de la ville du nom
de bateau livre dans ce vaste ensemble
architectural qui figure parmi les
grands travaux de l'État le public
dispose de 4500 m² répartis sur trois
étages pour lire étudier et apprendre
non seulement à l'aide de documents
écrits mais aussi grâce à l'audiovisuel
et l'informatique 270000 ouvrages dont
70000 pour le prêt 10000 compact disque
2000 cassettes vidéo 300 abonnements
magazine 51 logiciels exclusivement
réservés à la consultation sur place
Chambéry dispose là d'un formidable
outil culturel nous avons déjà un pôle
culturel très remarquable qui est
l'espace mallerau qui est abrite la
Maison de la
culture mais qui est plutôt tourné vers
les spectacles et quelques autres
activités ici nous avons
un un nouveau Paris à faire c'est de
faire une animation culturelle autour
des documents que ce soit les livres que
ce soit la musique que ce soit le
patrimoine symbole de la performance et
de la technologie de la médiathèque de
chambéie l'arrivée prochaine des
États-Unis d'ordinateurs permettant de
transformer tous les documents en
écriture braille ou langage sonore afin
que les malvoyants puissent eux aussi
assouvir leur fureur de
lire